that Republican Governor Joe Lombardo
keeping his intentions clear of wanting
to improve school safety so tonight
may get vetoed he is referring to ab-235
which passed committee while the bill
sponsored by the governor ab330 was set
aside both bills bring reform to
restorative justice and a statement from
the governor's chief of staff reading we
expect school safety legislation to
actually make schools safer adding this
is not good enough we need to do better
for our teachers and children now as for
the bill sponsored by the governor it's
been granted an extension so that a
compromise may be reached we have a
closer look at the two bills on our
website you'll find that at 8newsnow.com